We actually aren't looking for
a middle ground with capitalism.
We're not looking for a lighter,
gentler oppression, exploitation,
racism.
We are seeking revolution.
Yeah.
Okay.
My name is liberty. I'm studying
psychology at Ucla. I'm 20 years old.
I'm Sean. I'm 24 years old and
I'm in the Socialist Party.
My name's Mimi. Uh, 2016. I was the
Socialist Party's presidential candidate.
Uh, um, Shea and I'm with the
Socialist Party and I'm 28.
My name is Jack.
I'm 19.
I go to community college
and name's Richard 19.
I go to cal state long beach as a
chemistry major with a music minor. Hey,
get my socialists on the left and
Mike Capitalists on the right.
Okay.
Humans are inherently selfish.
Selfishness is sort of one word for it,
but looking out for yourself,
your own survival in your own gain.
Um,
and of course that includes the gain
of those you love is one of the main
motivators of people.
A really good way that we could figure
out human nature is by comparing it to
animal nature and stuff like
that. And you see, you know,
animals doing whatever
they can to survive.
It's just culture that has changed us.
But I believe at its core that yes,
humans just like any other
animal or I sell fish.
Yeah.
I work with children and my experience
of working with people who haven't been a
culture made it or have done in into this
idea that they need to be selfish all
the time are generally not every organism
has to have a sense of like getting
resources for itself
and we're just survive.
But that's a much different
than being selfish I think.
I think even if you look at, if you
spend any time in a social democracy,
you know,
let's say you go to Norway and you spend
time there where the people see, um,
the collective good, uh, as tied into
their own personal wellbeing. You know,
I think we have so many examples like
that societies working collectively toward
a greater good.
The thing about the Nordic
countries and my opinion is, well,
since there's very, very ethnically
homogenous, they all have very,
very similar culture.
It's not an accurate representation
of what humans inherently are.
Because I believe that culture
can mask um, human nature.
So you think that that diversity would
work against working in harmony towards a
collective good
in diversity?
We have different ideas of what good is.
I think competition brings
out the best in people,
especially when you know we're competing
for something like let's try to come
create this compound
that could help you know,
the masses and some kind
of health relation form.
You have all these research labs trying
to figure out what's the most efficient
way to figure out this process.
What's the most efficient way to do this?
I think we need more of that
sort of sense of competition,
especially in the sciences and whatnot.
You know, we frequently hear
about the evils of monopolies.
It's because you know,
with, when you control an entire
market, why even bother being better,
anything.
You've got no competition,
you've got nothing to strive for and
and no one can choose anything else.
I agree with you both on
the examples that you gave,
but the thing that I'm
kind of struggling with,
I mean if we're talking about
efficiency, quality, then yeah,
I think it brings out the best in people,
but then again,
it tends to bring about greed.
Okay.
Y'All do a such a great service. Uh, it's,
it's a trip to me because as you're
likely aware that there's this growing
support for socialism and economic system
that places people over profit that
you're willing to continue to throw out
the same talking points that have failed
people so miserably. Uh, again, it's,
it's a benefit to us and I
guess we should say thank you.
Nice.
If you care about something,
if you're passionate about something,
you don't need the threat of someone
doing it better than you to do the best
that you can do.
Ask any creative competition leads less
to excellence and more towards doing
whatever you can.
Did edge past the other person.
Yeah.
Today everyone has the
opportunity for success.
Yes.
All right.
If we're talking about the United
States and we're talking about financial
success, then yes, I would believe
so. If we're talking about the world,
it doesn't necessarily have to mean
financial wellbeing or like stability.
I think that it really just means how
you're happy and how you're okay with
yourself and you know,
you make a goal and you pursue your goal
and if you fail or a t exactly what I
was thinking.
I find that there are so many resources
out there that you can enact on.
It's just, there's some people who
just don't do anything about it.
Okay.
My first thought here with this collection
is, you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Uh, you know, um,
so many people in this country
who solely because they exist,
they're under threat. Whether it's
through, you know, the police,
they're just trying to survive.
So
everyone's very different.
Again,
everyone has different communities to
what they can even consider a success in,
in the u s though are a lot of
opportunities for most people though.
Of course,
you can't say all and there are always
those who are extremely unfortunate and
GB helped.
I'm sure every one of us was sat
in a restaurant before Starbucks.
Those people who work their asses off
any of these low income jobs are not easy
and they work for pennies. If something
goes wrong with their car, they're done.
You know, if they have a health
problem, they're done. You're,
you're talking about
financial success though.
Success is extremely relative and can
be defined in many different ways in a
capitalist society that wasn't financial
success, the most important thing. No, I,
I've worked in the food industry for a
number of years and I can not say that
any one of my companions
was ever happy to be doing.
And if they're going to school on
top of that, you know, so they're,
they're working full time and on top of
that they're going to school and their
pants school,
I would consider that successful.
If you can go to school and you can
maintain your GPA and you can also be
working a part time job and somehow
affording your school. Yeah,
you're doing well in life,
society should help the underprivileged.
Okay.
That sort of saying, give a
man a fish, etc. Holds true.
Um,
and also who should do the
helping and how is very important,
not all acts of service
are equally beneficial.
I would agree to that. I myself, you know,
I'm sorry to use a personal anecdote,
anecdotes here, but I've personally
dealt with the fact that, oh,
giving someone this much aid,
they become, they become lazy.
My father is an alcoholic,
so we,
since due to an injury in his leg,
he gets SSI and what's in,
what ends up happening is he receives
enough SSI to the point where he's not,
he's not motivated to do anything else
beyond just going home drinking a beer or
something like that. And I think,
yes, people should help people,
especially if they're under
underprivileged or they
need the resources to push
them put to what end.
That's, that's the fine line.
But your personal anecdote only only
covers the small demographic of the,
of the alcoholic. Most of the
people that, that, that uh, oh boy
you guys have brought up
has been specifically about
people who are particularly
poor when most of the country is middle,
lower middle class and
up hats. Lots. Actually,
that's not a fact that
you would focus on this.
And a con in a shitty one that gives more
than half of its budget to the police
in a country that just
passed the military bill,
a spending bill that's almost $1 trillion,
that money goes to defense contractors.
Government paying for things is not
capitalism, but we're in a capitalist, uh,
where the government pays huge
amounts of money for the military.
You're talking driver of those things.
How about instead of spending
the money on the military,
how about putting those back into basic
means? Healthcare, education, housing.
I agree.
The government taking our taxpayer dollars
and funneling it into they're paying
for things at the military
explicitly says that they don't need,
that's not capitalism is about
prices and transparency and,
and choices. When we got him
and takes her money and buys it,
they decided to blow some working.
That is not,
that might be what you call capitalism.
But when I come here and say, well,
I'm a capitalist,
I'm not saying I'm in favor of that
profit.
An ethics are opposing motives.
So I think at it's core to profit,
uh, you have to exploit. Uh,
and again there is nothing
ethical about exploitation.
Yeah. I mean I can't think of, I,
I'm really having trouble thinking of a
situation where someone could profit off
of something with that expectation
being in the mix and I just, I,
I'm running out of ideas. If you're
running a business and you know, you're,
you're the one up top,
you would obviously walk away with more
money if you pay your employees a little
bit less.
I think that profit in ethics can be
intertwined when seen with the corporate
social responsibility module,
when they treat their employees better,
they give them more benefits.
They raise their wages and in turn it
motivates the workers to work harder.
And treating your employees better than
shit is not necessarily ethical like
raising the quality.
It does not mean that you've phrased
it to a sufficient standard of,
of treatment. Because if you're paying
someone less than a living wage,
that is unethical.
All I'm saying is it is to some degree,
more ethical and can be seen as more
ethical to be beating competition by
raising the wages of your employees
and giving them better benefits.
I'll also,
one must be paid slightly less than they
are making in worth for a company for
it to be worth it,
to hire them at all.
If you can't pay your employee the
minimum amount of money that they need in
order to live a, you have no
business being in business. Um,
and I think also there's a tendency from
the conservative side to skew away from
sort of objective fact. I mentioned
the MIT living wage calculator, right?
Yes. That's a scientific model.
Wow. That 29 25 so as a company,
if you can't afford to pay
your employees a living wage,
that's just the minimum that they
need in order to live. Right. Ah,
get the fuck out of business.
Why are we even talking to you when you
have all the facts and we don't know
anything? I don't know. Hardly
worth my time. Well, we would,
sure it's hard to really lean towards
one side or the other if everyone is just
sort of stating all these coherent biases
and not accepting any sort of thing
from any other particular side,
which is why I'm sort of just,
I'm trying to understand your
side and I'm trying to understand,
grasp really my side of it.
And again,
going back to sort of that mutual
understanding of what can we do next,
that sort of mutual understanding
needs to be there. If,
if we're going to ever continue
to see what's best for,
for the US.
Well I think one reason why,
you know,
you often see like folks in the left
and socialist communist, anarchist, sir,
et Cetera, uh, they're so passionate
and there is anger, you know, um,
seeing the suffering and the oppression
and the exploitation, the racism,
et Cetera. You're sort of
feel this urgency, you know,
like we're constantly under sort of
this self criticism and self reflection
about like,
well how do you package what can be
complex ideas into ways that are very
palatable.
And I think every hour and I think
like if there is a failure on the left,
that would be one of them.
I wish that rather than having an
agenda that we try to prove and we see
ourselves as a winning by
convincing the opponent,
I wish that we could consider winning
as finding the middle ground and finding
where we're similar and finding the truth.
I think if you're in the pursuit of truth,
then you've won contrary to convincing
other people that you're right. You know?
Despite that we definitely disagree on
pretty much everything. It's good to know.
The real common ground here is where's
is like millennials and Gen z and stuff.
We're actually,
we're actually like talking about this,
like whether we were able to convince
the other side of anything or not,
at least we give a shit about it.
You know?
This is stuff that we
needed to talk about this,
this stuff that we need to be aware
of, especially given our leaders. So.
All right guys. That's a wrap. Thank you.
Really do.
You're cool people.
Okay.
Hey guys, thanks for watching the episode.
The middle ground here at jubilee,
we believe in this idea
of radical empathy,
and that is what middle
ground is all about.
So we want to hear your thoughts
on this topic and this discussion.
So let us know in the comments below.
Please click here to subscribe
and watch more of our videos.
Remember to live greater.
Yeah.